please
sit down dr hurst
i am dr roy
please don't stare
i apologize for the search but we could
not be entirely sure you were genuine
we've had quite a few people over the
last few months who sought to cause
problems with us but enough of that
our friend in the foundation gave me
quite a bit of information about you dr
hurst
of course we have people in the
foundation
your friend david i believe just last
week he sent us information on six
possible recruits
david gave you quite the glowing review
just what we need a brilliant mind and
able to do what must be done now that
last one gives me hope
let's have a look at this file shall we
ah you were involved in the alaska
incident
that was magnificent you should be proud
the research data alone was extremely
useful as i can see
a few casualties but these cannot be
avoided in our line of work
can they and you used another item to
stop it
you've been wasting your time at the
foundation doctor
you obviously belong with us
perhaps it's time i tell you what it is
we do here
in essence we're very similar to the
organization you just left
we're not as big i admit but i feel that
our very nature means we achieve
more much more as you will see during
your career with us
we have 326 items currently in our
position
actually with your welcome gift we now
have 327
take for example the human serum
inject it into any animal and it will
morph and twist into the approximate
shape of a human
the samples they had they looked away
but we had better ideas we injected it
into a human oh the results
this is what you will do
do it is not right to do because nobody
else is able to do it
it's for the good of the world doctor
we have many more test subjects in the
foundation
the officials in the countries we place
our facilities pay us to take their poor
their destitute they're useless
the people we use have nothing they are
nothing
but we can take them use them and then
they
are something aren't they
they are the future
i hope that in the future wars will not
be fought with guns
they will be fought with impossible
things wars will be ended in an
instant they could be ended before they
began
i am not evil but the things we do
have to be done
we will give you 30 test subjects for
your first two months
and access to two vertigo items
you would call these safe items we don't
bright new ideas doctor for a bright
new future
impress me doctor
i'm sure you will exceed all of our
expectations
you want to use the items on the
subjects as i'm sure you know how to
keep trying and trying until you find
that moment where it all clicks
and you're holding something that should
not be in your hands
when you find you are holding a weapon
you've done it
it's another small step doctor
another small step
oh the name
we are a small force against the tide of
impossibility
and this small force seeks to create
logic
out of illogic what better name
than the chaos insurgency
you